so I've heard and read so much about
shadow of Mordor and finally getting to
play it and I see what everybody's
talking about like and I'm really
excited about just the gameplay itself
this is definitely not a Sanskrit like
you get in there and you realize this is
a completely different game but the
Nemesis system and finally getting a
handle around this really weird very
hard to explain system oh it's so hard
to explain I feel like I need cards to
lay it on a table and so I can like drop
pieces of string to each one in order to
like explain how it works because it's
almost a collectible card game with like
this meta thing going on collectible
card game with orcs that you can pit
against each other and they will fight
for you and absolutely it's really cool
and they just gave a presentation which
is kind of the video that we saw so far
my eyes glazed over I fell asleep for a
very small amount of time because it was
really boring just listening to it but
once I finally got in there and they're
like alright so you need to go and
here's it work and you're gonna go do
something against it like whatever you
see his weaknesses and the strengths you
need to go fight him I'm like alright
fine I'll figure it out just by fighting
him and but then after you fight him you
basically have a choice like if you grab
them you can use them to your benefit
happen so make its other people they
become bonded to you yeah and you
dominate them with your like ringwraith
power but that's not the end of it
because it's not just they fight for you
in that moment they actually on the
chess board you can tell them to do
stuff so we have to explain there's
different ranks yeah at the very top you
have the war chief there's war Chiefs
and then there's just like captains or
whatever and the captains are also
different levels like at the top you
have the high level captains and the
bombing of your lowest level guys
they're also connected there's
bodyguards of the war Chiefs yeah so
some of the word chief are basically
friends there they are working together
with some of those captains yeah but
some of the captains are also
antagonists was went with one another
yeah so it's all interconnected in like
these really systemic ways and what's
cool is I decided okay this war chief is
my end game but to get to him I need to
go through this bodyguard because
that'll piss him off that was one of his
attributes or there's so many I'm very
colourful like it's from where we were
at I mean we're basically jumping in
nearly into the game but weren't still
not quite powerful just go in and pick a
war Chiefs ass
even close so I targeted one of the
lower dudes and being new to the game
totally got an AI elated but what that
did I was basically speeding him he
leveled up and then he killed another
guy and like ranked up in the chessboard
if you will and then I was like well of
course I'm gonna try and revenge him
because it like kind of gives you that
prompt like revenge yeah I'm gonna do
that and then you do it and of course I
still sucked so I just kept feeding him
and his his power level went higher than
like anything on the board but that
brings other peace so he who go and kill
another caps into that and that brings
other peons and that replaced the
captain that was killing yeah that too
and so eventually what I had to do to
its exact my revenge was bond a bunch of
the underlings and ennoble like you're
basically getting them it's - yeah it's
like mind control and so what what ended
up happening is had like the army of
dudes go after him for me and they just
leveled him instantly which is great and
then all of a sudden like he was gone
and I could and by having him level up
he actually dropped a way more powerful
rune which gave me like a 20% chance to
recover the elf arrows which is like a
whole nother [ __ ] thing we haven't
discussed like the the wraith elf arrows
system in all that [ __ ] it's like so
there's so many systems and they all
play together so nicely yeah whenever
you're fighting against one of these
guys if you kill them yeah if you kill
them in different ways you get different
items that will power up the weapons
that you have yeah which is which is a
whole other system on top of itself
but the captain's the way that they're
connected so you have the captain's who
are bodyguards of one another you want
to kill one of the you want to kill the
bodyguards first or else you're just
gonna have a hard time killing that
chieftain because he's gonna have a lot
of friends but if you have a chief if
you have a captain that you go to fight
against and he is being antagonized by
another captain you see a red line that
connects them when you go to fight them
that actually starts a whole other story
thing where this captain will come in
and you actually you'll see a cutscene
and there's a whole different
interaction and interplay and sometimes
the you can just sit back and watch and
they'll fight each other and then you
can take out the weaker one there was
one one really cool one that I saw where
where the captain one of them was a
traitor
and he basically had subdued the earlier
captain put them like put him down on
the ground it was going to
oh they're gonna do the execution they
were gonna execute him so I pulled on my
bow and arrow and I should I kill I
executed it for him oh wow
he still took the credit for it but then
I was able to go in and kill that second
captain oh man I was able to have one of
my lieutenants or whatever like become
under him and be his bodyguard after
helping him through some of these trials
like these mini missions that you go on
and so eventually I had an Inside Man so
I when I went and in order to like
actually oh this is like a whole nother
system to - in order to activate the
fight missions against those those
warlords you have to do like a crazy
side mission where this one was killed
20 normal yokai orcs without taking any
damage at all which was really freaking
hard and then that's summoned and that
someone's him but once you do that you
can reach summon him to get revenge if
you failed percent but basically I had a
bodyguard and then he came in and the
bodyguard helped me kill him building on
that my bodyguards became the chieftain
or the warlord I'm messing up all these
terms because but basically the dead the
head guy and then so what I did I pitted
him against another head guy and ended
up winning that battle but instead of
killing the guy that the warlord that
fell in that battle I bonded him but
then what I decided to do is I had this
ability where anybody that bonded to me
I just like des it's like and their
heads popped off it's like disconnecting
them from the matrix not like this boom
and they all died and then I got like
three different rooms super-powerful
rooms you can use them to fight against
other guys you can use them to also gain
Intel so you can figure out what
people's weaknesses are so like if
you're having trouble against one
chieftain and you figure out oh he's
actually really weak against ranged
weapons but is invulnerable to me like
all you have to do is like now that you
know his weakness go up just pull out
some arrows and as long as you take him
out from afar you'll like it makes that
battle so much easier it's crazy how
many how inspired these these systems
are and how much they play off of each
I've won and I haven't seen a game
action game that does this it's okay you
need it because money yeah it does tie
into to the main game itself and I think
there are some instances where you will
have to fight against these captains and
chieftains and get them on your side or
at least move them out of the way but
it's in a way separate from the main
story and it doesn't directly affect the
main story it's kind of like its own set
of side stories and side missions you
can go on and explore and power up your
weapons doing without affecting the the
main quests the main story so it's like
it's something that adds replayability
in a lot in a lot of ways because you
know when you fight these battles it's
different every time even when what we
saw where we're playing that in the same
position in the game the people that we
would meet these chieftains that we
would come up against we're completely
different the way that they interact
with one another the way that they power
up was completely original for both of
our game it sounds I'm sure we did like
a horrible job of summarizing this
really complicated all about the
anecdotal like stories that we're just
like talking about because that's what
that's what's so freaking cool about
that how the system's build on each
other value complicated set it against
you set things in motion and then see
what happens but it's easy to understand
what you get into it like it sounds like
this really complex system and it is
complex because of the way that it
interacts and those different things
that you can do but once you actually
sit in there and get into it like
actually this is really simple I
understand what's going on I know how to
affect this I'm gonna kick that war
Chiefs ass yeah and then that's not even
to mention how cool the combat is that's
a whole nother video I know oh my god I
want to play this game so lunch